[Music]
because
you know what we got to do we have to
read our patreon number
are we at the end of the episode yeah so
the new members of the matriarch are i'm
gonna start i'm gonna
he's first on the list but i'm gonna i'm
gonna put him last okay okay
brad seaman yo brad good name brad
seaman yes
this next guy's named mutated axe wound
mutated axe wound yep yeah that's a guy
you're gonna snapchat with for the next
couple of months yeah yeah but i didn't
i couldn't believe he seemed like a
normal guy yeah then he just showed me
pictures of victims yeah and then he
started sending me snapchats of his open
[ __ ]
with a picture of chris in there yeah
and i was like ah it's whatever it's
weird
yo here's my phone number text me when
you're in town yeah
um then we got no another spicario
oh my god that's his name i didn't can
you buy shanxia in his name
christopher penis paul ten dollars thank
you for your service christopher full
name
harrison ernseller aka harry sandusky
she's a five dollar member yeah it's
funny leo i'll give you a burrito after
i crack you open and clean you out
[Laughter]
libs the kitty [ __ ] and jab attack
missile pbw nominee
sue dupinus five dollar member yeah
are you gonna fart no okay i thought you
were leaning up miguel i'm 50 sure my
grandfather was a nazi that escaped to
mexico
next up ladder 14 jobs
and next up mike make no mistakes
periacci
that's a sauce monkey [ __ ] that's a
steroided sauce monkey
yeah and we got abel i got a situation
with the mother diaz
yeah we got casey crystal clear spoodus
this one this one brings up memories for
me this guy's name is father bill
father bill joined the patreon ppw
we're gonna have johnny 1 16th eastern
hemi
dan south jersey steel pipe pickings
chrissy
just a plain white dude with a decent
piece brewer
[Laughter]
because this is the app by far the
funniest listeners
up we got sesson fumes
and then we got millie slid into chrissy
d's dms when she moved too many
vegetables hernandez
claire wants a toot always a two towel
yeah
there you go she's good yeah um then we
got zach not a muzzy musgrove
then we got alyssa a piece of urine
curran
yeah yeah alyssa yeah and we got greggy
no
fumes greggy no fumes that's uh that's
could be top he's top notch for me right
now
then we got um then we got julian
kiwan aka closet fanuc with a [ __ ]
got alan my wife doesn't like my feet
fumes benson
cody hoosier hunka dunk hillard okay
reno the horned up sauce monkey
coronetti
yeah yeah so he went up he won the whole
fame already
got chrissy d hpv and me
got steel pie parentheses half jew half
fumes steve
then we got um then we got gianjo pay me
back i know you're listening
ah good one then we got andrew moon
yeast infection
another goodie yeah yeah then we got
jonah make no mistake i can't afford
this and i got a small piece to veto
he just took the number one spot you
like that yeah
robbie pumpkin pumpkin piece pearl good
one bobby pumpkin piece
um then we got chrissy no more herpes
yes please to stefano
so some people are just naming their
names chris stefano yeah yeah which is a
10.
then the next one we got patty fly your
balls on my uvula and call me father
bill
jim gill who just sounds like [ __ ] he's
just he's here for content
yeah the guys who just give their name
they're like look guys i don't want to
play the games i'm just here for the
comments
thank you so much yeah then we got right
wing lean for latter 14
nah mean jacob
you know these guys are the ones who
just do their names yeah you remember in
the old video
stores there was a porn section in the
back like behind a curtain
yeah like that private the ones who just
give their names are just the guys who
just hold it put their head down and
just walk straight to the back
yeah yeah jacob chester has his shirt
tucked in right he's got a shirt chucked
in he's got his head down he's just
walking back for the content
this guy's this guy's patron name is
chris nero i am sporos
kids my [ __ ] yo that kid's here for a
good time not a long time yeah that kid
went way back
yeah [ __ ] sports is what no nero was
wild episodes sports was his eunuch
yeah um then we got the next one up my
kids are 18. so no more situation with
the mother
good one then we got papa papa pushing
the gay down
i mean ten how good is that next up we
got gino makes pizza
wait put pushing the gate out is it good
pushing the gate down yeah
gino makes pieces see gino makes pizzas
that's a that's a curveball that comes
out of nowhere that's hilarious cheeto
makes pizza then we got
rodman definitely not a leroy but have a
piece like one lopez
because our fans funnier than we are our
fans are we can't possibly be
as funny without our fans our fans make
us so funny it's not even fun yeah
they're funny kids
i take some of the things that our fans
say and just say them in my stand up
yeah
i just [ __ ] steal from my fans yeah
then we got cynthia chrissy can use my
uvula as a bunch and bag flores
yes pseudo penis chrissy tegan
all right yeah people just then we got
zach [ __ ] the wall drop at nuke i want
to see a mexican anime
wow yeah he leaned into that one yeah
then
we got stone called ff steve austin
[Laughter]
then we got harry got a situation with
the last name pappas
that's a goodie yeah um then we got gen
piece of german puss puss coakley
because stoke called stoke called ff
steve austin did not be good yeah
ah then we got um joe popolodaro he's
walking back he's watching that
funny name yeah if you have a last if
you have a funny if your last name is
just real talent like that
you don't even have to make a name
you're just going to laugh at it yeah
like joe popolodaros hilarious
then we got haley went from leprechaun
to nazi after ancestry dna results her
verdi
that's like you yeah that's what you did
this guy's name is
chrissy claw stumps
then we got chrissy cracks and cleans
yeah there's case it's all case too it's
so it's three k's
yeah yeah so it's kkk yeah that one got
better tia
um then we got yanny brows went down get
him water uh yeah that's a goodie
ready on snow monkey sorry not swarthy
ruzika
i can't believe how [ __ ] funny these
are yeah aaron i can't get hard unless
you suck my pseudo penis babe alvarez
good one
good one leanne esposito that's my wife
she'll get disciplined yeah yeah um
then this next guy is just probably
neighborhood guy stevie bananas stevie
ian og tbg dec peace police friedman
[Music]
wow yeah those kids those kids are here
for a good time not a long time if you
[ __ ] play this game you're
here for a good time not a long long
time doctor dump and pump and pee inside
you
yeah ten kim i'm a little upset cause
chrissy d hates doing the podcast carney
yeah yeah mikey i got a situation with
chris's mother now curtis
okay this guy's cleaning out my ex and
he's not mean curtis last name curtis
yeah i guess i'll see you at the [ __ ]
next birthday party yeah mooji mike
emoji could catch a cacciatore
and we got josh probably potato monkey
but i'm not sure because my mother
had a situation irish kid irish kid
welcome to the [ __ ] patreon
then we got then we got this one we read
already we read to each other but it's
an all-star one
yeah we got this is we honest had said
that this name could potentially be
number one and shut it down this one is
mike
punching through shooting goo where you
poo dominique yeah that's number one
yeah repeat it for me again mike
punching through
shooting goo where you poo dominique
yeah yeah
cause if that's not the [ __ ] michael
jordan of patreon members
i don't know then we got frank from
brooklyn but takes a year to plan a
night out in the city
then we got yeah then we got bonnie give
me headley
good one veto i got a situation with the
mother spaghettios
then we got alyssa got a situation with
the father alyssa's got a situation with
the father then we got jimmy the
fumeless armor yeah he's
that's a good one but he should you know
he just had to you know how a lot of
guys were born into the era that jordan
was
yeah i'm just going to call him clyde
drexler he's clowned because ordinarily
he'd win a championship but we got
shooting goo in the poo yeah then we got
sam like my coffee leroy
but not my men ladder 14. falcone
that's one thing yeah then we got dj the
yam mean but a low-key ff
good one brought back the ama i'm gonna
have to
listen i just want to clarify i just
want to before i say this i just want to
say like i
joke around with a lot of the stuff that
i do i joke around i have a
uh multi-ethnic family i grew up in a
multi-ethnic place i joke around with
my heritage it's just it's like a
character piece it's a funny thing
ladder 14 i genuinely i'm just kidding
but
you know unfortunately i this guy jared
forthright schrader
so and i know that i caused that yeah
it's your fault yeah
it's it's okay but i'm just kidding
around i do not i think the nazis are
disgusting
of course these are disgusting we joke
around but he is a german kid his last
name is straight up schweiter yeah
yeah i'm honestly just kidding around
that part of that culture unfortunately
horrifying
sounds like that kid's not yeah i i
don't think anything they did was right
they had a couple of good science
experiments but that's another thing
kidding you cannot um asleep thank you
give us a double
okay next up johnny dad says i'm half a
fanuc cook
same because if your last name is
italian like real talent don't even
worry about making nikki because we just
laugh at it
dean villani
yeah yeah yeah um this one kyle and then
parentheses my
son pronounces aju a jew so he gets a
cookie
dude that's he tried to do a triple back
flip i like that even got uh
kevin a situation with your mother fumes
samson
so he's just he's just some people just
want to put all the things in and yeah
that kid's walking into the [ __ ]
video store with a hawaiian shirt off
yeah and we got uh
mike fuhrer a fume sayer yeah there you
go good job
um then uh last parentheses my friends
want to launch me back over the border
carandaza
yeah we got a white walker we got travie
balls and [ __ ] sallows
there you go and umberto i wish i was
white perez
did you write that did you read that one
already umberto i wish it was white
perez
no uh we didn't read up but welcome
welcome to the bay truck
next up taylor non-tuned cute and ready
to flute the poop shoot brag
i mean just ken just give him the crown
then we got jacob jesus was just here
for the content sent his jew's ass to
the bat
grazer oh boy yeah where should she be
hello jacob yeah you've created some
monsters yeah i'm just
kidding listen do you have to understand
i'm joking on the pod yeah he's joking
joking joking and you don't have his
charisma so stop
fabulous toot with a cute poop shoot
lawrence
i mean it's almost like they
collaborated together for that kid's got
a cute poop shirt yeah
um then we got chrissy's strong [ __ ]
shooting out of sprinkle dick
then we got mikey feral snow monkey
fumes weber
good one yeah people just are putting
words together yeah then we got joey i
can't believe i shaved my balls for this
dubs
good one yeah then he said matt came for
a piece but we'll end up with
pete's foursome
yeah wow matt chrissy d cracked me open
and eight lakeside maple out of my smash
bean
because this kid is justin joined so i
don't get beat up by anthony
at the live party then we got witch
hazel doucher
10 somebody got ladder 14's bulldog
mascot adolf hitler
laughs one thing bob throw them in the
microwave wilson
it's just funny but you can't laugh
that's a reference but you know what
japan did attack us first yeah they did
attack us
that's a reference you know it's amazing
that sushi restaurants just keep opening
up i mean you know never forget
um duke gizza of come town
um crack open my bean and smash it into
my jeans
okay richie don't know where the [ __ ]
i'm from but i got a tiny piece curtis
[Music]
oh god dominican immigrant here legally
but avoiding chrissy forthright
uh sauce monkey epstein good one good
one danny long balls ferraro
okay that's funny yeah no fumes mike
shadow rope and chrissy d's butthole
while bill burr watched bed
oh one more tyler eastern hemi with skin
covered in sin
italiano yeah then we got cody crack me
open and clean me out with a side of
sauerkraut german yeah benjamin straight
to the front let's drain the swamp of
marinara monkey
chrissy d's catapult white walker's
assistant trump 2020.
joe cuz he was he non-toot chrissy boots
aka [ __ ]
cute oh no sorry sorry
joe cuzzy wuzzy non-tuned chrissy's
boots are [ __ ] cute
i mean that kid is [ __ ] hard too yeah
you just got new boots funny kid green
eyed leroy with a microwavable glue gun
and then we got tyler the lean mean half
bean eating ice cream for the protein
then we got tony balls the half bean
weishan sheehan machine and
uvula feen that is a 10.
uh sergio not white but votes to the
right it's character piece
that's okay nike nunsey fat sauce monkey
corleone
yeah it's a goodie larry not a leroy but
now have a situation with one dot dot
dot chrissy sit on my lap
rosa straight to the back parks sid the
screwed in kid who poos on kids graziano
he went for it but you know gra
he could have just said graziano yeah
it's fine um
sandbox sammy simple and good
justin no toots wasp roots unfumed pubes
groomed and by myself i'll take you
physically
just put that on the list yeah then jake
uh cbd cured my autism i mean anxiety
it's a character piece but not really
but father bill mulrooney chapel 14 it's
a character priest
h.s jr gave me a tonsillectomy because
father bill's dick through hands
[Laughter]
michelle make no mistake i will x-ray
your bony moroni and laugh at it
you got ricky two nuts
[Laughter]
you gotta get ricky two nuts you gotta
get a dog
uh brian crack me from the back in the
love sack and set the microwave galeo
and we got cat half sandy half scandi
removable shower head equals negative
fuel
that kid put him on a list yeah
chrissy cousin cracker justin chrissy
micro d
eating yani long dong's reese's
character piece
pretty good yeah uh old johnny non-two
don't suck your flute ortiz
[Laughter]
then we got uh fuzzy wuzzy was a muzzy
cuz he fumes ladder 14. yeah he's a
goodie
smucker fuckareli stick my dick and
jelly
[Laughter]
zach not a muzzy but down with isis
bowers
i think that kid's making just more of a
political statement fumes you can taste
shouldn't go to waste b
ready to bring chrissy d to poughkeepsie
for the boys
put him on the left bobby 1-800 no more
toots
baby these nuts got fumes but still
cracked open jake father builds a pedo
cause he touched my pink torpedo
chicony my piece burns probably the clap
kyle
yeah johnny i'll crack you open and
clean you out two times
okay next up lauren looks like
pocahontas but gives a blowy like ursula
greco
danny slurp it till i serve at splurgeon
but it's burning devito
jeff not epstein consensually cracking
open
ham wallets you tuck it i [ __ ] it
theo von's mullet
not an ff was just experimenting don't
tell my dad he voted for trump
stosh big dumb pollock aka adolf rolled
over my boys thanked brooklyn jesus for
that
goody that's goodie from philly chris
can you ask your dad to give me my debit
card back
jesus christ yeah it's such a goodie uh
brian thick ass with a thin piece badeem
jim i've got a sore my piece so don't
tell my wife barry
jake the jew goldstein
uh dolph cute non-fruit but we'll crack
open the glutes lombardi
nicole chrissy crack me open on the
united nations porch
international waters what are you gonna
do now your glasses are on sideways
you're gonna go down
yeah i just i feel light-headed i'm
think i'm done
oh are you gonna like can i just read
the patreon name i just read the page
all right i'm just gonna read the
patreon names we're having a medical
emergency with giannis but
i'm just gonna read the patreon names
quick laugh or don't laugh if you pass
out i know it's a good one yeah
whoever's the ppw
this one is who's makes yana's head hit
off the [ __ ] table got set straight
to the back
and split crack primo dante sent the
salami to your boy in the army spot
fedora
ian janitorial manager collar bluer than
my catholic balls anderson
louis non-toot non-fruit loop discolored
piece half greek pipsqueak
i get asked if i'm a muzzy in every
bodega melendez
georgie porgie put it in pie crack the
girls opened and made him say yes
chrissy cracked me open and tiramisu a
new one
that's pretty funny yeah 4 20.
[Laughter]
mussolini chose right pellegrino it's a
goodie too
jorge no papers bean i'll sit on your
lap for a green velasquez
uh reish marshall andrew schultz
andrew i'm irish but my last name puts
me on the no fly list malik
a very lonely glue gun andy father bill
is not my father but makes me call him
daddy
chuck the cuck jk just a character piece
pendexter that's lachlan not screwed in
yet but i'll suck your bottom lip
johnston
thanks for the casinos cuz true blue
native chrissy butt slots puddles and
nuts in my guts
michael woke while smoking dope and
stroking my pseudo penis
chrissy d's come stain lovesack maddie
matriarchy the honest of gowanus aka
chrissy cracks [ __ ]
loose booty cable guy tucks and [ __ ]
anthony franks and beans
christopher 8 inches of salami but three
of them a foreskin heath bar
stevie dip it low like robert moe mateo
giannis dick slap mike stan mourinho
joe i think it's an std panzerella oh
yeah italians
jess parentheses i got full-blown fumes
rob pound my polish bag chrissy d you
nazi beefcake swarovski
the pollock with the kielbasa that make
no mistake is in your daughter
matt i'm an illegal immigrant so my glue
gun is a little different donato the
sauce monkey trapped in rockaway beach
the ogiacomo
german kid that looks like a sauce
monkey no fumes dark pubes
yeah corey the blonde hair blue-eyed
russian truffle pig kuznetsov
danny i may be trans but you can still
catch these hands mcglynn joey turn me
round spank me down and call me 420.
[Laughter]
nick not an ff but i got ibs mastro
giannis
nice piece two that cracked open and
cleaned
out and with the ziggy
yeah yeah yeah next up we got hamid the
sand monkey with fumes ready to go boom
aloo akbar muzzy life yeah
he called himself a sand monkey
all right the ex toot chris play with my
skin flute
holy [ __ ] then we got matt the screwed
in new haven potato monkey no fumes how
you doing
yeah then i got aj i have a situation
with the mother because i cracked open
her sister
shane i break ass cheeks not hard flint
and genie
then we got harriet tuckman the bun
humping potato monkey
kyle the massive bologna and macedonian
that's a good
he's he's in the contention last but not
least we got yoni p
has a half clean bean you know what i
mean obviously the winner
wow the last one ended it yeah thank you
guys so much for watching we hope you
loved it
don't forget to click subscribe and turn
your alerts on and go to patreon.com for
more fun where things get really wild
[Music]